i have so much fun watching this show
it's uh
definitely i you know i have been
missing them as i'm sure you've been
anxious to get the show back out as well
so
what did you most enjoy when it came to
the shenanigans that she gets up to this
season what are you most excited about
fans getting to see with these new
episodes
um well thank you first of all for all
those lovely words um i'm really excited
personally for people who like season
one to see all of the doll face girls
going into the magical realism element
of the show so in season one
the cat lady and that kind of whole
thing is a way of for jules to kind of
act out her anxieties and her worst case
scenarios
whereas this season all the girls come
into this so it becomes
cathartic not just for jules but like
izzy and
stella and madison so it's really
exciting i'm excited for people to see
that
when you started talking to the cat lady
did you have any idea what that would
develop into and how important of a role
it would play and were you ever
worried that it wouldn't work
you know what i'm so lucky that i get to
work with beth grant the absolute genius
icon that she is and she was the only
person
i mean i will take credit for this
because i said we need to get beth grant
from the very beginning before anyone
was cast it was just
find a way to get beth grant because
she's the only person who can do this so
somehow she agreed and we have her so
with beth
it's it's so real if if you can believe
that a huge cat head person can be real
she throws herself into all of her roles
and she
just takes you there with her in these
scenes so i knew that we had something
very special happening and that she
would
evolve and
they're always the writers are always
trying to give
her lots of things to do
um so that's just incredible for me
you have some fun moments this season
two moments in particular that stood out
for me were the music festival and the
dance class
with the dance class was there ever a
moment where you considered trying to do
the performance of the dance routine
yourself or were you always just like no
i'm not gonna do it
interestingly jules was scripted to do
the dance and what happened was was i
was filming
other scenes while all the other girls
got to do dance rehearsal
so
real jewels me cat
uh
i had to have a moment with our
showrunner michelle nader and just be
like i cannot
just dance
so either you're gonna have to cut away
from me or you just have to write that
jules is really bad at this dance she
was like you know what i think we can
find a really funny way to do this and
it ended up being one of my favorite
moments in the entire season uh jules
spoiler alert jules gives the dance
instructor a doctor's note to get out of
dancing so it's a very relatable moment
i think it's more jewels than doing the
dance and i think
that's what i would do too
how was it shoot the whole music
festival what was it like to pull all
that off and make it seem like such a
big moment
kind of done in a more intimate way so
that everybody i would imagine stayed
safe doing it
exactly so that was a real
feat for our amazing dp and the crew and
all of that so they
uh not to give away the hollywood magic
but as you said you know it's it's about
staying safe so we had our safe group of
background performers and they would
like maybe change clothes and
come back or like walk through a few
times so they made it look really packed
and busy while only using
our safe extras so it was it was really
amazing they did such a great job
everybody was
all about you know safety the cast
background performers the crew
so it was a group effort but i think it
paid off really well
yeah i mean it looks amazing and it's so
much fun and i just i thought it was a
really kind of genius way to pull all of
that off thank you i absolutely love the
friendship between these characters the
dynamic between these four is so fun to
watch
what have you enjoyed about finding it
as characters but also just as
co-stars working with these other
actresses
oh my well i love them all so much and
we really have
the real friendship going on and i think
that's part of the magic of the show is
seeing
four real friends interacting because
you can you really can't fake that kind
of chemistry you know so
obviously season one we got to know each
other really well and we all miss each
other so much because
obviously something happened in between
season one and season two and uh we
didn't get to see each other at all so
this was just you know so amazing to
finally see them all again and
it was just a really special kind of
bonding experience brenda describes it
as like summer camp you know it and it
kind of was like that we see each other
for 15 hours a day
um and we're in little you know little
pods together and i mean brenda and i
text each other from the same room so
we're all very close
were there conversations about how to
handle the pandemic in the show and
whether to address it at all how do you
feel about the way that it actually gets
incorporated and then we move on from it
yeah definitely of course like i think
some shows may have chosen to just not
do it at all
um but it's so it's it just that didn't
feel authentic so archer runner michelle
nader um who is a brilliant genius who
i love more than anything um she kind of
took the helm on okay how do we do this
we actually had a different
opening in season one and she changed it
close to rap close to the season wrap to
make it what it was let's see all the
girls during the pandemic and what was
that like and were they together in a
pod and what were they doing so i think
it was really important to show that
like jules and madison and the girls got
to be together
um during all that so their friendship
got even more strong
um and of course the comedy of like
jewel spraying her mail and stuff like
that which i did do so what
um yeah so it's dealt with a light hand
but we did not want to ignore it um and
doll face in its own way is sort of a
fantasy so it the pandemic like going
away of course is not realistic but
for the show it seemed
you know like the right path
how involved are you as a producer on
the show are there aspects where you're
really involved and give a lot of input
are there things that you found that you
enjoy that you didn't know you would
enjoy before doing it
yeah i well season one especially i was
extremely extremely hands-on and
involved just because this was my first
like
big thing since
my last show i was on so i wanted to
really make sure that this was going to
be
great you know and my first big
executive producing thing that i was
doing so i wanted to do the best job
that i could um mainly like finding the
best actors for the roles which of
course everybody was involved in but i'm
so proud of being able to do that
because as an actor like
casting is terrifying
uh
so i'm really proud of of how everybody
came together and season two
i still am very involved but because
michelle nader is there as our
showrunner somebody that i have worked
with for like since two bro girls since
the beginning of it so like 11 years
um i trust her completely and she's like
another arm so i could kind of
calm down and relax a little bit this
season
what is it like to establish that
collaboration between
showrunner and the writers and the
directors
how is it to find a voice among all of
that
it's really really important a show
runner is the most important element of
a show sometimes like that's the person
who's the go between all the departments
so that's a hard job you know and
michelle is just
unbelievable i mean she and i have a
like secret language shorthand already
so i don't even have to worry about that
but you know she'll just text me and be
like okay what do you think of this what
do you think of this i'll be like okay
great and then it's done
um
so she has like
tentacles like going into every single
aspect of the show and i completely
trust her it's a very rare relationship
it's very lucky um
i don't know it's almost like
like a
ben affleck matt damon relationship
except on a way like different scale
she's the ben affleck
no wait she's the matt damon
well even even though jules isn't 100
sure of what she does want by the end of
this season do you feel like she's at
least more centered and more sure about
what she doesn't want yes that's a
really good way of looking at it season
one she kind of is just things are being
like hurled at her and she's just kind
of like trying to get through it you
know so
she's done all that work
and i think she's more ready she's more
ready to
let things in season two but so much is
happening to her that's good that she
kind of doesn't know what to do again
so even though she's made all this
progress
she she can't fully
work through it so in a way she has
definitely grown and she's more
competent especially at work and more
confident in herself but she has a long
way to go
have you already started to have
conversations about where she could go
for season three do you try not to think
that far ahead i'm superstitious so i
never i always assume like one and done
for everything i don't think i decorated
my dressing room at two bro girls to
like season five um i always assumed
like
i just had to have my bag packed so yeah
i don't really think about it but of
course that'd be incredible and they're
all sorts of dream scenarios i'd love to
see
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it this show is so fun it's just
delightfully entertaining so thank you
thank you so much